[Music]
what if all the Earth's land became
ocean and all the oceans became land and
what if our mountains turned into deep
trenches while trenches grew to the
highest peaks on the planet imagine what
this new world would look like we're on
this sprawling land mass would humanity
live and why would this planet have such
a hard time sustaining life this is what
if and here's what would happen if
Earth's topography was inverted of
course with the volume of water in the
Earth's oceans inverting our topography
would mostly look like we flooded the
planet where's the fun in that
let's eliminate some of the world's
water so that the seven continents
become oceans and the seabed becomes one
big interconnected landmass it's fun to
think about but what if I told you that
a world like this would have one major
design flaw as far as we know the ocean
floor is pretty boring
topographically speaking by and large
it's mostly a vast plain at an average
depth of 3700 meters below sea level
that means except for the Mariana
mountain range our upside-down world
would be a huge plateau and it would be
well above the sea level we're used to
the thing is the human body doesn't
handle high altitudes well most of us
live about eight hundred and forty
meters above sea level our inverted
continent would be more than four times
higher than that there would be less air
pressure and less air - we'd have to
adapt to living in a low oxygen
environment if we wanted to survive but
that's just the beginning of our
problems an inverted Earth would be
barely covered with water
the Himalayan trench would turn out deep
but the rest of the seabed wouldn't we'd
be left with for shallow oceans and one
vast never-ending continent on the
bright side you'd be able to walk to any
part of the world but with little oceans
left you prop
wouldn't want to go too far inland
anyway right now 71% of Earth's surface
is covered with water the surface of an
inverted Earth would only be 29%
submerged oceans control our climate
distributing the heat from the Sun
evenly throughout the planet less water
surface would mean less evaporation and
precipitation as a result most of the
land would become a scorching desert too
hot and waterless for humans to survive
you'd want to live close to the oceans
away from the unbearable temperatures of
the hot land but you might not stay
there too long either
with so little water oceans wouldn't
absorb enough carbon dioxide greenhouse
gases would build up and stay in the
atmosphere slowly cooking the planet
life on Earth might resemble life on
Venus there be no fresh water left to
drink all the plants would die and all
the animals would follow shortly after
humans could build a shelter to hide
from the unbearable heat but food would
be scarce it would be hard to figure out
how to preserve the existent life in
such conditions but could life have
emerged on an inverted Earth
theoretically yes and it would have
transitioned from sea to land much
earlier there simply wouldn't be enough
real estate at the bottom of the ocean
if that evolutionary cycle led all the
way to Homo sapiens human anatomy would
be very different maybe we would have
evolved to be cold blooded to be able to
take on the high temperatures of our
inverted planet but that's a story for
another what if
you